Sarah Chen: Good morning everyone. Let's keep it quick today — I know we've got a lot going on. Marcus, kick us off.
Marcus Johnson: Morning. So yesterday I finally got the ClickHouse schema locked in for issue #68 — closed that out. The partitioning by service and date is going to make our aggregation queries way faster. Today I'm starting on the latency query API, that's issue #69. Should have a draft endpoint up by EOD.
Sarah Chen: Nice. And quick heads up on a decision — Marcus and I synced with the data team yesterday and we're going with ClickHouse over TimescaleDB for the metrics backend. Benchmarks showed 3-4x better performance on the aggregation queries. That's final. Priya, you're up.
Priya Patel: Yeah so the notification tray component, issue #63, is coming along but I'm running into a tricky issue with real-time badge count updates. Right now we're polling the REST endpoint which means there's a lag. I need to hook into the WebSocket event stream but that depends on Marcus's fanout work in #62. So slight blocker there, but not urgent yet.
Marcus Johnson: Yeah, let's pair on that tomorrow afternoon. The fanout worker is mostly done — I'm just cleaning up the error handling. One thing: we agreed to drop priority queuing from this sprint. All notification types get treated equally for now. Keeps things simpler and we can add priority tiers in a follow-up launch.
Priya Patel: That's fine by me, honestly. Also, the alert threshold UI for issue #71 is done and shipped — QA signed off. Feels good to close one.
David Kim: QA side — I've started smoke testing the notification event schema that got closed yesterday, issue #61. Everything looks consistent with the CloudEvents spec. I do want to add some edge case tests around the custom extension field. Should have a report by end of day. No blockers.
Alex Rivera: Quick thing from me — the staging Kafka cluster had a blip this morning, about 15 minutes of downtime. It's back up. I'm adding a health check alert so we catch that faster next time. For today I'm picking up the dashboard frontend work on issue #67, getting the time-series chart component wired up with the new metrics API once Marcus has that endpoint ready.
Sarah Chen: Great. Let's keep an eye on that Kafka reliability — if it's flaky in staging it'll be a problem in Beta. David, can you log that as a risk?
Sarah Chen: Before we wrap — a couple process things. I've been thinking about triage. Right now I'm doing it solo every morning, but honestly it's getting to be a lot. I want to move to a rotating triage duty — one person per week handles the daily triage after standup. We can start next sprint. Thoughts?
Marcus Johnson: Yeah, that makes sense. It'll also help everyone understand the full backlog, not just their own stuff. I'm good with that.
David Kim: Agreed. Also, can we talk about the stale issue cleanup? I noticed we have like 40 issues that haven't been touched in two months. Right now it's a manual monthly thing — could we automate that? Like, have a bot flag anything with no activity in 60 days.
Sarah Chen: Love it. Let's do it — Alex, can you look into setting up an agentic workflow for stale issue cleanup? Auto-label them and ping the assignee before closing. We decided in last retro that 60 days is the right threshold.
Alex Rivera: On it. Also, one more process thing — we've been doing PR reviews with a 24-hour SLA, but honestly most of us are reviewing within a few hours anyway. Should we tighten it to 12 hours for non-draft PRs? I think it'd unblock people faster.
Priya Patel: I'd support that for normal PRs. But let's keep 24 hours during on-call weeks — the on-call person is already stretched thin. Maybe we do 12-hour SLA for regular PRs, keep 24 for on-call engineers.
Sarah Chen: Good compromise. Let's go with that. And one last thing — Jordan asked me to mention that she wants to move design reviews from Wednesday to Thursday. She's finding that Wednesday is too early in the sprint to have meaningful designs ready. Starting next week.
Marcus Johnson: Fine by me. Oh, and one more thing — I've been manually compiling release notes before every GA launch. It takes forever. Can we automate that too? We already have all the issue data.
Sarah Chen: Yeah, that's a great candidate. We'll add it to the workflow ideas list. Alright, that's everything. Good standup everyone — have a productive day.
[Multiple voices]: Thanks, bye!